usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticado con cáncer de
próstata este vídeo le ayudará a
entender cómo manejarlo el cáncer de
próstata es un tipo de cáncer que se
forma en la próstata del hombre la
mayoría de los casos de cáncer de
próstata es de crecimiento lento y puede
no causar síntomas o problemas sin
embargo es muy importante tener un plan
de atención con seguimiento esto incluye
tomar los medicamentos prescritos según
las indicaciones de su médico
tome nota de cualquier efecto secundario
e informes él oa su médico pregúntele a
su médico qué hacer si ha olvidado tomar
una dosis
si usted no puede pagar los medicamentos
pregúntele a su médico acerca de otras
opciones para obtenerlos
hable con su médico antes de tomar
suplementos de venta libre o
medicamentos a base de hierbas
vaya a todas las citas con su médico y
para pruebas de laboratorio
cumplir con estas citas le permite a su
médico revisar su afección y ver si
necesita tratamiento adicional
si usted se ha sometido a cirugía de
próstata o radioterapia siga las
instrucciones que le dieron también
puede ser necesario hacer algunos de los
siguientes cambios de estilo de vida
saludables no fume y limite la cantidad
de alcohol que bebe
ambas actividades pueden aumentar su
riesgo de cáncer reduzca el consumo de
sal y alimentos altos en grasa tales
como la comida rápida
coma una dieta saludable con más frutas
vegetales y granos enteros
una dieta saludable puede reducir el
riesgo de que el cáncer regrese
manténgase físicamente activo el
ejercicio y las actividades diarias
pueden hacer que se sienta mejor tenga
en cuenta que algunos tratamientos
contra el cáncer pueden hacer que se
sienta muy cansado
pregúntele a su médico qué puede hacer
para sentirse menos cansado saber que
tiene cáncer puede ser abrumador
es posible que tenga preocupaciones
sobre su afección y cómo afecta a su
familia
tratamientos y estancias en el hospital
gastos médicos y su trabajo
afortunadamente hay maneras de lidiar
con esto
recuerde que su médico y el equipo de
salud están allí para responder a
cualquier pregunta que tenga las
siguientes fuentes de apoyo pueden
ayudarle a abordar sus preocupaciones
trabajadores sociales líderes religiosos
consejeros y grupos de apoyo
hablé con su médico si tiene alguna
pregunta sobre su plan de tratamiento
medicamentos o cambios de estilo de vida
que lo ayuden a manejar el cáncer de
próstata